Nói Nguyen quan vụ 5 xí lốc 12 tử vòng so tên an xa thông ử sát thư pân.
Đặc lắc, khu ngay bà mi thằng tư năm 2020, công an tính đặc lắc cho biết
vừa có kết quả giảm định dung tích xe gần máy nhấn hiệu ASB RRO, Mô Sơn đến bà.
Mà miệng số 4 miế bẩy AB, bà hai năm bẩy tâm, là phương tịnh trong vụ tên ngại.
Thều đó, phòng kí thật thình sự đã tính hành giảm định, kết lợt,
dung tích đồng câu gần trên xe tại thư điểm giảm định là 1 trong năm 2019,
xe gần xe xe gần máy nhấn hiệu ASB RRO, tương tự được người ra mạnh,
sau khi xuất sự là mẫu xe còn xung tích đồng câu bố miếc chính phy năm 2020,
hai còn gọi là xe năm 2020. Nếu vậy, xung tích đồng câu của phương tịnh trong vụ tên
hạnh tăng có phương bà lần so với thiết kế bà đầu.